That cheeky devil Lucifer is back and he's
having one hell of a time on Netflix!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and today
I'm going to reveal some devilish details
about season 4 of Lucifer including cool easter
eggs, ingenious foreshadowing, secret cameos,
and more things you may have missed.
Obviously, spoilers ahead if you're not all
caught up.
If you were shocked by the season 4 finale
where Lucifer confessed his love to Chloe
and then banished himself from Earth to sit
on the throne in Hell, then you'll be even
more surprised to know that moment was cleverly
foreshadowed right in the opening scene of
the season.
The premiere episode begins with a montage
of a lonely, melancholy Lucifer singing Radiohead's
"Creep" at his club Lux.
Chloe's absence and the throne-like art-deco
background behind Luci predicts how he will
end the season: alone again without Chloe,
sitting on a throne overlooking Hell.
The reflection of Lucifer in the piano also
foreshadows how split he'll feel this season
between his more and less devilish sides and
also how he'll travel from the Earth above
to the Underworld below.
And, in a really clever detail, as the opening
montage plays out, Lucifer's clothes change
with each new day, finishing with him in a
white shirt and dark suit with a little red
handkerchief in his breast pocket.
And that's basically the same outfit complete
with red pocket square that we see him wearing
at the very end of the season when he's sat
on his throne in Hell.
When Chloe visits Father Kinley he shows her
a scrapbook of some of the problems he says
were caused by Lucifer's previous visits to
earth.
"Once we uncovered Lucifer's identity, we
were able to uncover evidence of his previous
visits with humanity.
You're...
You're saying he caused the Chicago Fire and
Nazi Germany?"
And when the detective turns to the page of
clippings from Nazi Germany, there's a photo
with none other than Lucifer standing there.
However, the devil does not look impressed
with the people he encountered and, I think,
what Father Kinley has misunderstood is that
Lucifer's very likely there to find out all
about the humans he'll be punishing later
in Hell.
In fact, this links back to previous mentions
of Hitler on the show:
"How did you actually torture Hitler in Hell?"
"Hitler was a talker.
Well, screamer, actually."
"Shouldn't you be, uh, I don't know, having
tea with Hitler by now?"
As for the Chicago Fire, well that's a cool
easter egg to one of actress Lauren German's
previous TV roles.
The Great Chicago Fire was a real fire that
raged for several days in late 1871, but of
all the historical events that the Lucifer
writers could have picked, they chose this
one as Lauren German, aka Chloe, starred in
two seasons of the TV drama Chicago Fire where
she played a paramedic!
And it's tricky to make out, but there is
a "Lucifer Morningstar" listed on the check-in
page for the hotel in Chicago.
When Fox cancelled Lucifer after its third
season, Lucifans responded with a resounding
'hell, no' and got straight to work online,
letting everyone know just how much the show
meant to them.
Thanks to their online campaign, we got our
deepest desire: a fiendishly good new season
on Netflix.
And there's a sly wink to the show's former
fate, when Father Kinley hands Lucifer his
business card.
"Vatican investigator?
Sounds like a soon-to-be-canceled TV show."
And in a grateful shout-out to those many
fans who helped raise the series from the
dead, the show's writers titled episode 9,
"Save Lucifer", which is a lovely hat-tip
to the hashtag Lucifans used to blow up twitter!
There's a particularly touching moment mid-way
through Season 4 where Amenadiel tells Chloe
just how proud her father is of her, and the
way he says it shows that he's seen or spoken
to her father in heaven.
After all that you've been through, Chloe...
what you're worried about most is what's best
for those that you care about.
No wonder your dad is so proud of you."
That revelation is actually a moving reminder
of some of the final words Chloe's police
officer dad said, just before he was murdered.
"Just tell her it was a good movie.
Kids these days.
Yeah, I know.
But, hey...
I'm proud of her."
By the way, the actor who played Chloe's father
in those flashbacks in season 2 is Chris Payne
Gilbert, the real-life husband of Lesley-Ann
Brandt who plays Maze.
Speaking of Maze, she gets some hilarious
scenes as always in Season 4, but there was
one particularly intriguing moment in the
first episode when she's visiting Linda.
When the Doctor encourages Mazikeen to open
up about her guilt after hurting Trixie last
season, the demon is more than a little reluctant
to discuss her emotions.
"So let's talk about what you're dealing with
emotionally.
Yeah, I really don't want to.
Maybe it would help if I spoke your language.
You speak Lilim?
[speaking in Lilim in a deep voice]
What?"
In a little shout-out to her birthplace, South
Africa, Lesley-Ann [Brandt] has revealed she
was speaking Afrikaans.
And if you were wondering what she said, well,
the official Twitter account for Netflix South
Africa posted her Afrikaans dialogue.
I put that into Google Translate and here's
what it means in English:
"Can you understand what I'm talking about,
because I want to talk to you and you can't?"
The role of Eve was actually written with
actress Inbar Lavi in mind from the start
because one of Lucifer's writers was a big
fan of her starring role as a con artist in
the TV series Imposters.
And what a great choice she was as her decision
to go full-on playing the original sinner
Eve with all the excitement and innocent wonder
of a Disney princess with an extra naughty
side was absolute genius.
And there are lots of lovely little touches
in Eve's scenes from her drink of choice:
an apple martini, to the apples at the bar
and in other scenes.
Then there's her arrival in a heavenly white
dress with a killer pair of fiery heels, to
her later appearances in clothing that's various
shades of red.
And there's even some foreshadowing of where
Lucifer and Eve's new relationship is headed
by the end of the season in the lyrics of
the song playing just before Luci discovers
she's back on earth.
Also, Eve's conversation with Father Kinley
includes an amusing nod to the opening lines
of Catholic Confession, "Forgive me, Father,
for I have sinned."
"Forgive me father..
I am Eve."
Music's always been a big part of the show
and there've been some great musical moments
this season, kicking off with Lucifer back
at the piano, singing his heart out to Creep;
Maze declaring her love to an oblivious Eve
by singing Wonderwall;
and Luci, Ella, and Dan getting their groove
on in the season finale with a little throwback
to Dirty Dancing.
Indeed, that toe-tapping season finale could
well pave the way for a full-on musical episode
next season according to co-showrunner Ildy
Modrovich who's been eager to get the cast
in full song-and-dance mode for some time
now.
And it looks like actor Tom Ellis would definitely
be up for that because not only is last season's
Luck Be A Lady Tonight scene one of his favourite
moments in the show so far, but he's also
said that the dance sequence in the finale
was his favourite filming moment of Season
4!
By the way, we might have never heard Tom
break into song on the show if it hadn't had
been for a cast and crew night out.
Originally, the plan for the series was just
for Lucifer to play the piano, but when the
writers heard Tom belt out Mustang Sally at
a karaoke bar, they discovered their lead
actor could really sing and decided to include
it in the show!
Remember the sequence where Amenadiel approaches
random strangers in an effort to connect more
with human beings now that he's decided to
stay on earth?
Well, when out of the blue he stops by for
a chat with a woman who's working on her laptop
in a coffee shop, the woman he's interrupting
is actually played by one of Lucifer's showrunners,
Ildy Modrovich, who also wrote this very episode!
And Ildy's co-showrunner, Joe Henderson, snuck
in an easter egg to another one of his creations
in the scene where Maze and Trixie make up
at the police precinct.
Trixie is reading a comic book called "Skyward"
all about the adventures of a young woman
born into a low-gravity world, and Joe wrote
both the comic book and the episode it appears
in.
Trixie's previous reading material in the
show has also provided interesting easter
eggs, for example, the book "Coraline", that
her mother read to her, was written by Neil
Gaiman the co-creator of The Sandman graphic
novel which introduced the Lucifer character
that this TV series is loosely based on.
So, were there any other cool details or easter
eggs you spotted in Season 4?
And what were your favourite moments?
Tap left for my full breakdown of the season
finale plus my season 5 predictions or tap
right for another video you're sure to like.
Congratulations to the winner of the last
round of my Avengers giveaway.
Send me a message from my About page so I
can send you the prize!
And if you enjoyed this, a thumbs-up and a
share are hugely appreciated.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!